was the amazon series that they that
they cancelled season two of because it
was too real
utopia that was another i don't know
when after did you just say you have to
watch that one it's about a tech a tech
billionaire who's worried about
overpopulation he makes fake me wait and
this was on amazon amazon
he makes fake meat he's concerned about
overpopulation and climate change so he
stages a fake pandemic to rush through a
vaccine before proper without proper
approval
that secretly is sterilizing people
you're still talking about a tv show tv
show
there is a comic book that reveals
what the plan is and what's going on and
it's the comic book is called utopia and
so when they find it they're looking
through it to figure out clues for
what's happening in in real life because
whoever wrote this has privy to
information so it's like a whistleblower
is writing in the comments mad scientist
so that was a part of uh doing so let me
explain to you it's a tv show where they
find a piece of art and media that
explains them a tech billionaire who's
worried about overpopulation
is pushing a pushing through a rushed
vaccine with a fake pandemic to
sterilize people now now let's talk
about reality
in the real world
we have a team a piece of art that
claims to say that there's a tech
billionaire who who's concerned about
over population but as we all know
our tech billionaires are concerned
about overpopulation yeah they want fake
news
just care
no i've been diving deep into the
metaverse this last couple weeks that's
one thing i've been doing i i got turned
onto this woman melanie swann by um
allison mcdowell thanks alison who's
very skeptical about blockchain and how
it's basically a big tracking mechanism
this fascist global organization is
going to use blockchain to track people
they want to create what's called
decentralized autonomous uh
communicative service a d a let's see
what this is called oh i think i'm
coming through loud i hope you guys like
this decentralized autonomous
corporation as a block the blockchain is
a brain they want to upload everyone's
behaviors thoughts and feelings to this
blockchain together to create this uber
mind and then just track it and do what
do what i don't know because a lot of
this code is private elon musk is
building you know brain interface chips
and they're all talking about the
metaverse which is pretty much online
digital heroine from my perspective it's
hilarious
like people will go off about bill gates
but then elon musk will come out and say
no i literally want to put a chip in
your brain yes and then and then nobody
says anything they're like no but he's
cool but elon also attacked crypto
because it was allegedly bad for the
environment you know so so again right
there's these we went on snl and
attacked it too exactly so there's a lot
of things that the billionaires are up
to that i think they have way too much
control way too much power way too much
influence and they got there because of
government and now they're using
government for their own personal
benefit and the billionaires are getting
super rich right now from from one year
their wealth increased i think it was
319 billion dollars someone needs to
correct me if i'm wrong one year the top
wealth of nine billionaires increased
319 billion dollars you saw that photo
by the way of jeff bezos down on his
yacht oh yeah getting serviced by the
ladies service by the lady with the lady
with the mask and he's there like
glistening in the sun on his super yacht
just like you know like the you know the
uh developing immunity it will it will
not be a
this is the yeah and so it will be
metaverse is how they right exactly
is how they establish elysium right
because the neo-feudalism and then the
elysium tech aspect comes in because
you're distracted you're distracted by
and look palmer lucky like i love you
dude i think you're a good guy and all
but like
why did you give oculus to mark
zuckerberg man come on he would have
done it this was a step back
he would have done it regardless he
would have done it regardless but this
this is where it's going and i by the
way i saw zooby just had a uh just got
booked in the metaverse so he's going to
be playing a a show what um
does did he say a website there's a few
of them now there's central land as one
yeah is it is it a place it's multiple
places
it's like a place
is meaningless what people keep saying
in the metaverse it's like yo there's
been second life there have been apps
for this forever sure and now they're
just calling it a metaverse or the
metaphor you're gonna integrate finances
in with it crypto great branding i got
into um yeah mark zuckerberg's brain
it's also the the the phrase used to
describe a nightmare dystopia but sure i
got into this decentraland bill ottman
ceo
this is how they do it man
this is how they're gonna do it is
you're going to be hooked up to this and
mark zuckerberg is going to be down at
st bart's and his life's going to be
getting longer and longer and his yachts
are going to be getting bigger and
bigger and leonardo dicaprio's islands
are going to be increasing and he's
going to be bringing more and more
people down there while he talks about
climate change and all this is going to
be going on and you're going to say oh
did you see what's going on on metaverse
you know you're going to be in a pot
eating the bugs you're eight year old is
going to be making money on the
metaverse and going to be completely
dependent on the system it's going to be
terrifying dude totally
from birth plugged in from birth little
kids in the womb might be playing games
with their thoughts the matrix and
digital heroine i think that's more of
an accurate depiction because when
people are hooked on it just like they
are social media you see them in the
grips of what the algorithms make them
and what they're doing to people
especially young people is absolutely
horrible
the polls understand this inherently
you'll need to explain this to us i just
figured it out what you got
so in star trek what happens is you know
that from cochrane he discovers warp
technology right as the vulcans were
passing by and the shuriken first
contact first contract
um in our reality
the borg was just passing by uh well
that is
we were in the one where they changed
then right because that's actually the
plot of first contact where they go back
in time and it's the borg that comes but
then
they make first contact and then you see
for like like a glimpse right where what
the future would look like and it's like
a borg world instead of the earth yeah
toxic gas the atmosphere is diluted so
the humans are just assimilated
immediately yeah yeah the entire planet
no not immediately it's that it shows
you what the 24th century would look
like if the borg had made first contact
rather than the vulcans so for those
that are familiar with those nerd stuff
the borg is a a race of uh they're
people who are assimilated with
technology into a hive mind like
digitally and so they all become
mindless drones basically everything you
just said it's like a dc a decentralized
autonomous corporation yeah so what's
going to happen
so do you see what alex jones was saying
when he went on that rant and he was
like alien intelligence has taken us
over and i'm sick of it and like he
recently was yelling that i mean he's
been yelling after 20 years
but artificial intelligence could be
considered alien right because it's
brand new it's defined
alien yeah and and
he might not be wrong especially with
how fast ai has been developing and it's
larger consequences of it creating
god-like authority and what putin calls
the new nuclear weapons that will be far
more devastating on humanity and the
country that develops it first will be
the ones controlling the world so
there's a lot to to unpack there but uh
he might he might not be wrong there
let's be real this is what yuval harari
he calls it homo homodaeus right human
gods human gods and and i think there's
there's a whole metaclip of this where
it's uh it's elon musk on rogan and they
they intersperse it with alex jones on
rogan and you actually hear that they're
saying the same things right they're
talking about the exact same things alex
just does it in a more bombastic way
elon does it in that like softer more
mercurial kind of way but they're
actually describing the exact same
dynamics and forces at
absolutely it's kind of like um
they say if you keep using old tools to
build the modern system you're just
going to end up with an old system
because you're using old tools so you
use this we're building the tools that
we will use to build the future it's
i've been doing a lot of math in the
last couple of weeks and like the
fibonacci sequence you take what the
past number added to the current number
to get the future number so past numbers
one the current number is one the next
number's gonna be two everyone forgot
and that's what technology is doing
everyone forgot what yoda taught them
we're going to be using this this
yoda's most important lesson of all
we are luminous beings we are not this
crude matter
hundred percent i think we're the brains
you ever see the picture the brain stem
connected to the brain with the
brainstem in the eyeballs have you ever
seen that picture yes do you look like
an alien that's what we are floating in
that's just no in china that's just your
interface man in china right now
in china right now to go anywhere you
need an app yes and there's the viral
video out of israel where the guy needs
the green pass do you see this one
mcdonald's mcdonald's and then if you
click you don't have one it just resets
yeah it just kicks you out just you're
just this is you're just not this
doesn't exist it's all necessary for
transhumanism
if if if we're going to
uh
in order for transhumanism to exist
people have to step above the human
experience it no longer can be about
carnal pleasures dopamine family
traditional anything
the human race has to be looked at like
lab rats or chickens in a farm or not
even a farm like a laboratory to be
controlled to be mapped out and that's
what these people are doing now they'll
probably end up building an artificial
intelligence that will start guiding
that behavior but ultimately the way i
see it is
you have single-celled organisms and
eventually they become multicellular
organisms well single cells go about
their business and do their thing but in
the human body you have highly
specialized cells that that do basically
one thing but they're cells right
i think that's how they view the human
race each individual human is just a
stupid human going about its business
and if we fuse all the humans together
together we can make a multi-organism
system
a higher plane of existence i think that
is part of what they want to do
basically creating a hive mind put
everybody in the metaverse put everybody
in the system have all their brains work
as like decentralized computational
power but it's going to require everyone
to be it's going to require homogenized
cultures homogenized behavior so what do
they do
everybody get your green pass everybody
fall in line and those who don't will
it's friction in the system right you're
mentioning friction
you make a system where it's extremely
difficult to exist outside of it and
eventually given a few generations
people will not exist outside of it or
they will be but they'll be irrelevant
yeah there's there's a very um
there's a very american
ideal that you know i will die for
freedom i will die for the right to make
my own decisions and i will you know
sacrifice myself on the altar of liberty
if if need be and i and i think that
that's that is sort of the american
ethos right um but at the same time
just look at the last two years right
humans comply the by and large the
majority of people will comply and as
the water increases right the boil the
boiling temperature of the water it
increases it increases it increases and
some people will say hey i think this
water's getting hot hey guys i think
these these waters are getting maybe we
shouldn't be in this pot anymore guys i
don't know what we think they said that
guy's crazy he this water isn't getting
hot i feel fine right and yet the water
is getting hotter and hotter and hotter
and then eventually you boil and
meanwhile everybody who jumped out was
called crazy for jumping out in the
first place and i think that's closer to
human nature and i think that we've seen
by and large the distribution pattern of
human behavior has been that look uh
when you come to america when it comes
to liberty when it comes to the
revolution you know people say it was
like less than a third of the american
colonists actually supported the
revolution actually went along with a
little bit more
it's i did a i mean it's hard to yeah
but just really quick before we jump
into that point but there's also a
florida man that don't give a damn that
baits in it and then
alcohol and that's not true excuse me i
was not i'm not i was not bringing
florida man into this there is no need
much love no need to bring floyd do you
know why the myth of florida man is
based on sunshine exactly and they have
we we all know about that but but there
is wait wait break break break that down
because that doesn't get said enough
yeah there's a records release laws like
if you commit a crime in florida the
public has a you know right to know a
lot of states don't do that so you'll
constantly hear stories about florida
man doing something yeah it's just
because they release the information
because they release the information
other states don't yeah we're all like
if you're bored just look up florida but
not in a particular day that being said
that being said if you go to like
western florida that there's florida man
down there i did a lot of research into
how many people supported the revolution
and there's a famous letter where i
think medman ben franklin wrote a third
support it a third don't care a third
oppose it but that's not true that was
just like a talking point it was just
rhetoric okay the the the best i could
find was that
it was like if i was going to give it a
number because i don't think they gave a
number they said uh a a plurality but
not a majority around 30 to 40 like 38
to 40 supported independence and then it
was like 20 something percent that
opposed it and then the next group was
uh completely neutral but uh it was it
was i don't think it's as cut and dry
that most people didn't care i think
that that i think that is true so i
think my math might be wrong but it was
like
it was a mix
the best i could find it's not it's not
easy was that a large portion if not the
majority like the plurality wanted
independence and the next biggest group
was leave me alone i don't care i won't
have nothing to do with this then you
had opposites if you had loyalists you
had the tories or whatever they were and
that's and that's why canada exists by
the way yeah quebec said no yeah because
that was originally going to be the 14th
colony right so there were you know the
canadian colonies were still there was
no separation like there is now it was
just the north american colonies but a
lot of the tories moved up to canada and
said no we're going to fortify this area
this was benedict arnold's original
mission by the way going through the
great lakes to try to take those tory
colonies didn't go so well um he gets
mad that he says he wasn't supported by
washington et cetera as he flips that's
the whole story canadians overlooked for
promotion but there are actually
if you go into this this was the
american invasion of canada yeah no we
did invade uh we we did didn't we we uh
the united states tried taking montreal
burnt and burned toronto what was 1812
at the time it was no no this is well
yeah that's at that and then so at the
time was called york is what i was gonna
say oh wow and then so the burning of
the white house was kind of seen as like
a response to the burning of york thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time